[Musique]
ah oui
là on va tourner la séquence du clip
apache mostar c'est ambitieux parce
qu'on va faire ce soir
c'est très ambitieux
[Musique]
tous ceux qui vont traverser la route
qui vont prendre la route ce soir qui
vont voir le périph hervé sellin cause
et moi c'est vite passé sur la voiture
plus de tommy robinson la réciter que
c'était un virage j'ai jamais vu ça dans
un clip un mec qui conduit une porsche à
toute allure et en même temps qui rap
qui fait son couple et je vais envoyer
tout est prêt et maintenant ça va être à
mon petit gars de d'assurer parce qu'il
va vraiment devoir conduire cette
porsche gt3
fermez le périphérique le porte de
clients course qu'à part dernière
c'était quelque chose c'était super cool
je la paix d'esprit c'est un peu
surréaliste quand même non c'était fou
on arrive sur le périph vide le périph
étaient à bout le matos qu'ils y tuer
les caméras les les bras c'était c'est
un truc de ouf il pouvait pas me le
retirer en passant tout
[Musique]
c'est bon maintenant on va passer à
l'intérieur de la chapelle d'agression
c'est franchement futur prix nobel
mon avis à tous au moins une main sur le
volant et des fois tu fixes une caméra
en ferrari de l'est de là en fait ya pas
une caméra sur le côté qu'il fait c'est
moi je regarde les gaufres
j'appelle moi seul et on dirait que je
suis tombé tard je regarde on vous taxe
carbone rappelle d'agression federer
après franchement futur prix nobel
c'est le plus fou c'est quand
et chez toi sur ton mac en train
d'écrire mais là ils bloquent le
périphérique il prend une porsche gt3 et
il fait une pointe à 300 kg ha et six
mois après si elle purifie débloquer la
porsche nra qui perd
[Musique]
une création originale à découvrir en
avant-première en ce moment sur my canal